so he did a time-lapse of me turning on
my computer going to print it out
realizing I only printed one copy at 60%
scale so the text was really tiny so he
came back and film me doing it again you
get four copies at regular scale and
then you film at fumbling a piece of
paper
it's our intro is all about paper here
did you just sign this NDA
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
Peter Piper light you're after into the
breach Monster Hunter generations
ultimate The Walking Dead Okami HD dead
cells hollow night for tonight
overcooked Tucson sanctuary inside limbo
Wolfenstein - doom Crash Bandicoot
insane fill new Minecraft stardew valley
celeste undertale gone home diablo 3
eternal collection the Jardins between
tower fall fifa 19 bastion transistor
dark soldier master warframe Dragonball
Fighters child of light Starling
Windjammers Lego DC super villains
Megaman 11 football menator 2018 team
sonic racing those are all switch games
but Nintendo didn't make any of those
games right it was kind of funny because
last year we had Mario + rabbits Kingdom
battle was a third party game on a
switch we had in terms of third party
like partnership we had Metroid Samus
returns on 3ds despite the fact that
more publishers were showing third party
support for Nintendo on the switch as
opposed to the Wii U which is kind of
like dark days for third party support
in Tendo this year is just like almost a
bevy of third-party titles on the switch
yes someone's gone from like last year
was you know Zelda Mario first party
titles now of a sudden it seems like the
switch is the go-to console if you want
to play a game period yeah well it makes
yeah but it's got a huge advantage over
other consoles yeah it's portable yeah
right which makes a huge difference for
a lot of games like there's a lot of you
listed there's a lot of people saying
that they don't have that great of a
release schedule this year or like if
they're just trying to cushion you know
the release schedule until smash bros
releases on December 7th sure disagree I
would say this release schedule is
awesome yeah we might have played all
these games before or some of them
before but like you said it's portable
we can actually just like they become a
whole different experience when they're
on the switch yeah I love this strategy
I don't think we have to necessarily
like look at Nintendo and say oh they're
not doing a lot this year like that's a
big problem or something but they did
make great Hardware right and that's
currently being recognized and everyone
loves it so yeah like I'm really stoked
to be getting all of these games to have
had a lot of them last year and to get
so many more in the future like stuff
that I literally thought well that's
behind me I won't get a chance to play
that now I kind of have a baked in
excuse right I didn't think I'd play
hyper light drifter anytime soon but
that's coming out as we miss recording
it's coming out next Thursday I'm pretty
excited for that into the breach that's
amazing
the fact that into the breach came to
switch before I came to mobile is pretty
surprising because when FTL went to
mobile that was like my preferred way to
play yeah I'll do to Holland I jumped
from PC to switch before I went to ps4
and Xbox one it's not even air that
people talked about Halle Knight this
year last year there was a few people
who were like you should play this game
[Music]
oh it's a good example as his dead cells
obviously dead cells was early access up
until this year it came out on all
platforms this year officially it's
almost like they're getting a new lease
on life on the switch
obviously hyper light drifter was
popular but I would not be surprised to
see it blow up again much like Holly or
Hollywood much like hollow Knight did to
get these like Renaissance is for these
games I think it's awesome that
Nintendo's giving them this second
chance so to speak it's good for
developers to like you here's I can't
think of any like specific examples off
top my head but I've heard developers
say our game didn't sell on Steam period
then we brought it's a switch we sold
you know hundreds of thousands of or
whatever like they basically yeah a new
lease on life but like an actual lease
on life like a chance for the game to
succeed I'm gonna play devil's advocate
yeah aside from smash ultimate if I'm a
Nintendo fan what else why should I be
excited to have a switch we've kind of
already talked about well you mean for
the rest of this year the rest of this
year going into spring there could be
some stuff that we don't know about yet
I wouldn't be Nintendo they do that once
in a while right they'll announce
something so I don't want to say like we
know everything's we definitely don't
yeah I want to give a shout-out to super
mario party I've traditionally not cared
about that series but like the last game
if I remember incorrectly was really
tied into amiibo and that was when
Nintendo was like gung-ho about let's
find a way to make amiibo the thing that
people latch on to it didn't work no one
liked it it kind of ruined the game
experience to the bringing back
Mario Party without a bunch of that junk
as far as I'm aware but then they're
also allowing you to put multiple
switches together to make custom game
boards for the games you are playing so
even though I don't like Mario Party
necessarily right I do like the Mario
universe and characters and I know that
Nintendo is great at making little
mechanical things like little fun little
games even if they're not huge ones they
can do like the nitty-gritty of game
design really well pairing that with
like a really unique way of matching up
two consoles or handheld it's like
that's pretty cool I want to see what
that's about if you're looking at like
sony's catalog for the rest of the year
they have spider-man I'm just coming out
in like a week is that it as far as
first pretty exclusives for Sony I'm
probably forgetting something I mean I
know there's Forza horizon for for
Microsoft right there aren't that many
first part exclusives coming out the
rest of the year and if you're a sony or
you're at Microsoft you think they're
worried a bit at how much third-party
support the switch is getting who knows
I I think they're definitely aware of it
right like they've got to be trying to
do something to ramp up awareness of
their own platforms
I still like think in the next few years
we're gonna see someone else probably
Sony try to mimic what didn't endows
achieved with switch maybe risky as hell
but like at the same time like can
someone really sit back and watch
Nintendo run away with this you know
convertible console and that'd be the
thing that gets people so excited like
can they really stand by and let that
happen without them it's not just a
portability but I think if they just
like they work on that console whether
it's because of its like actual I think
the controls kind of just fit but
there's like been very few games I
haven't fit I think darkest dungeon
despite how much I've played that on
switch the UI doesn't really carry over
well that's the thing too is that you
don't see a lot of utilization of the
touchscreen despite it fitting the form
factor of the system like stardew valley
didn't have touch controls a lot of it
has to do with the fact that like well
that's designing controls twice if you
really think about it because it needs
to support both the controller and
touchscreen so why bother
I wish the joy cons are a little bit
better mine has finally started to like
fail in certain ways like the the
wireless radio on the left one's not
that good and I've known so many people
if I'd have Joe Kahn's replaced yeah I
absolutely love the Nintendo spec I mean
it's it's absolute like it's obviously
the thing that I use when I'm traveling
and everything but it's also just like
become my preferred console for wolves
that could be on PlayStation what what
is my play on switch
what what what wouldn't you play in
darkest dungeon I wouldn't play anymore
but there aren't many things I wouldn't
play I wouldn't play like realtime
strategy on the switch I don't think
there has been much realtime strategy
what would you not play on the switch
probably a competitive first-person
shooter I just said before there's a lot
of people who feel like especially the
second half the year is a bit off for
the switch again
probably make the argument that it's off
for every council that's just if you
care about like console wars right if
you care about that but I would argue
it's driving and I really really
absolutely love like we simply get these
games I have second chance on this which
we get these games that like just feel
like a whole new experience when they're
portable we have these games that I'd
prefer to play on Swift graphics isn't a
problem and like the actual visual
fidelity is not a concern for me I would
prefer to have a game on switch over any
other platform like PC included would
you still want the switch if there
weren't intended games on it yes I would
because I'm not really playing it right
now for a first party stuff smash will
be great yeah so like when I hear people
talk smack about the switch for the rest
of the year and what they latch on to is
Nintendo's output I feel like we're
having to turn conversations point
[Music]